hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast how do we effectively screen
and manage opioid use in the community
presented by dr. Carissa Vandenberg
Clarke an assistant professor in the
research division Department of Family
and Community Medicine at st. Louis
University of School of Medicine
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of labyrinth I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web cenomar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to you via email if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on the ask a box
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credit tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
dr. Carissa van den Berghe Clark I will
now turn the presentation over to her hi
everybody
again I'm cursive Anand Burk and I'm
over at st. Louis University's
Department of Family and Community
Medicine I have nothing to disclose
except I have a few grants from the NIH
focused on cardiovascular disease and
PTSD as well as a grant from McCrory
focused on focused on psychiatric
transitions of care today we're going to
talk about the chronic pain in the
opioid epidemic then we're going to go
into how this is translated into the
community specifically with a focus on
primary care in emergency room
additions after that we'll talk about
challenges to implementation and
dissemination of best practices so
opioid epidemic by numbers a hundred and
sixteen people die from opioid related
drug overdoses per per day 11 million
people misuse prescription opioids in
the US and this year if per year 42,000
about 42,000 people have died from
opioids prescription with with opioid
deaths there There is obviously an
association with increased access so as
we see starting in 1992 there's been
significant increases in the number of
prescriptions for opioids that were
given out you know basically around 2010
to 2013 people became aware of that that
these opioid prescriptions were were
actually causing a significant amount of
harm so many physicians in many states
started regulating more the use of these
these opioids and fewer prescriptions
went out people there then also at the
same time heroin became more available
so people began switching over so we see
the increases of heroin use and we also
start seeing as something that go poh
started hitting the streets a lot of the
heroin use switching over to synthetic
opioids this is also explaining what is
going on with the increase in opioid
deaths that have been going on in the
past past few years you know so you can
also see this very well geographically
its parts of the country where there is
a lot of prescriptions given out there
is also a lot of deaths
the the issue the difference here though
is that opioid use was in some ways
encouraged by the medical system this
all started with dr. Mitchell match max
who basically was the president of the
American Pain Society at the time he
wrote an editorial very famous editorial
in the annals of internal medicine in
1990 basically stating that pain is the
fifth vital sign and that patients don't
talk about their pain with their
healthcare providers that's a real
problem and they have when they get any
kind of opioid medication they have a
very difficult time getting the provider
to adjust their dose if they don't get
opioid medications they have a very
difficult time getting them basically
health care providers don't believe that
pain and relief is their job and at
least according to Mitchell back said
during this time period and there there
was no expectations that providers would
be able to reduce pain so basically dr.
max had given a bunch of recommendations
to to the to physicians to make pain
more visible he also thought it was
really important to develop bedside
tools for change to guide physicians and
nurses to initiate and modify analgesic
treatments they wanted he thought that
it was important to assure patients a
place in the communications loop
increase clinician accountability by
developing quality assurance guidelines
improving care systems and assessing
patient satisfaction another
recommendation was to facilitate
innovation and exchange of ideas and
then there was the most
so one of work with Narcotics Control
authorities to encourage therapeutic
opioid use this the last one is one that
is obviously going to haunt him so in
terms of quality improvement one of the
things that started happening to make
physicians more responsible for pain
there was they began to basically
recommend using measures like this brief
pain inventory to measure pain on the
part of patients and basically they need
to show changes in pain relief over time
so this sounds good
and then we entered the complexity of
the medical world when the chronic pain
patient shows up so what is chronic pain
chronic pain is essentially when
somebody has any kind of pain that lasts
longer than the recommended time of the
injury that or it basically lasts more
than three months for a non back pain
condition and more than six months for a
back pain condition so following this
this requirement of the three and six
months we have about a hundred and
twenty six million people who consider
considered to have chronic pain in the
US so that so on
it's almost room fifty five percent of
the u.s. adult population about six
point three percent have very severe
pain that means that they have pain
every day and they have a lot of pain
every day and essentially the impact of
chronic pain includes basically a large
number of bodily complaints and
essentially heightened proprio and enter
o captive awareness
chronic pain is associated with multiple
disease states and it counts for five of
the top years lived without disability
conditions globally month much of the
time people with chronic pain also
experience symptoms of cognitive and
emotional distress they have a lot of
dysfunctional pain behaviors like
physical inactivity they sleep a lot
they also have a lot of relevant somatic
and psychological comorbidities one of
them a major ones is depression so of
these who seeks care and who doesn't
seek care what we basically have have
seen with with this is about 40 to 75
percent of chronic pain patients consult
with a health care provider about their
pain and these people usually have more
severe pain what we see here is there's
higher there's a higher pain severity
more interference with daily life
there's more spread of pain there's
lower quality of life
there tends to be lower income less
likely to be employed also who seeks
care tend to be older female white or
mixed race less educated poor Western
states or those who seek care tend to
have worse health overall they have more
fatigue higher depression high
anxiety more healthcare utilization and
more disability so basically what's
going on only individuals with chronic
pain and the sphere end are seeking care
these people have lots and lots of
health care problems not just the
chronic pain oftentimes lots of
psychiatric up problems often times lots
of comorbid chronic health conditions B
city heart disease hypertension they
also they also oftentimes people with
chronic pain oftentimes delay care or
use other means in which to decrease
their pain so in 2014 alone US retailers
dispensed 245 million prescriptions for
opioid pain relievers sixty-three
percent of it was was prescribed for
less than three weeks and three to four
percent of adult population prescribed
long-term opioid therapy
so shall I shall at all uses a random
sample of healthcare claims and he found
no different demographic differences in
risk of long-term opioid use but someone
who gets a scrip for more than eight
days is is basically much more likely
and this is 13% of people who who become
long-term users they're basically much
more likely to become a long-term user
of opioids my mentor dr. Jeffrey share
basically looked at the number of of VA
and civilian electronic medical record
registries and found that opioids were
usually causing depression so what's
interesting about the sample is he
basically did a washout period where
there was no depression and if you look
at this kind of this top this top line
there's no no depression prior to
getting this part this chronic pain this
diagnosis of chronic pain and and
basically they get a new diagnosis after
opioid use
so what is the typical long term user
opioid user so you know essentially a
lot of times miss users are tracked
within medical records for by having
these certainties specific
characteristics and this does have an
effect on how physicians decide to to
prescribe so gender is not a predictor
of misuse but younger age is why it is
predictor of myth of misuse but data is
mixed because the samples are usually
white there's a history of substance use
substance abuse there's a history of
psychiatric disorders there's a history
of legal problems and there's a history
of traumatic stress
so how do patients feel about chronic
pain patients
so early studies show that physicians
showed little concern this is a study by
there was a study by Turk at all in 1994
and it showed that a sample of 6,000
over the around 7,000 US physicians they
showed little concern about tolerance
dependence and addiction or state
requirements so then we look at you know
as we start kind of running into this
opioid epidemic problem and we look at
later studies of 2010 and onwards there
is a significant concern about
regulations and addiction on the part of
physicians so physicians start getting
more worried and so they start looking
they start getting much more careful
about prescribing when it comes to
patients that have a background of
substance use disorders and psychiatric
disorders but they also begin to have
troubles with their chronic pain
patients or generally physicians often
describe their chronic pain patients as
abusive or difficult they often felt
pressured to treat with opioids they
were not sure they believed patients
reports of pain they were worried about
secondary gain and diversion providers
felt that treating these patients took a
significant emotional toll on them and
they often felt frustrated ungratified
and guilty so what about patients
patients describe sub-optimal into
interactions with providers when seeking
care for chronic pain they from the
minute they walked into the door they
felt disrespected and distrusted they
felt like they were always suspected of
drug drug seeking and their symptoms
were often dismissed as trivial and not
warning medical care patients also saw
barriers to seeing providers promptly
when having
a pain episode and providers access to
pain documentation and many patients
felt like a burden both to the providers
and office staff so what does this mean
for care this means that patients feel
like physicians ignore issues about
chronic pain while physicians think
patients are always talking about pain
patients feel constantly in a position
of having to prove and document pain
patients like feel like they are treated
as drug seekers so what does this mean
for care we basically did a study of you
know me and my me and one of my mentors
dr. Sher who also did the depression and
chronic pain study we did a study
looking at patient trust for a physician
and physician trust of patients and this
was a study of chronic low back pain
patients and so essentially when
patients had a very high level of trust
for physicians
there was really no differences in the
way that physicians trusted them but
there were big differences when we
started looking at what paid whether
patients used opioids or didn't use
opioids whether and patient beliefs
about opioids if patient believed that
opioids work best for them they were
they they basically received a much
lower level of trust from their from
their physicians they if they believed
the patient themselves believed that
they took too much medication they also
were much more likely to have not high
physician trust on the part of their
patient of their physicians the doctor
shopped I mean we didn't have that many
people who reported that they dr.
Schaack but there's a trend here you
could see
and we did see some differences in terms
of age and whether there are applying
for disability so the the patient the
physicians were also kind of making some
kind of demographic assumptions of the
part of patients whether they trusted
them or not trusted them so what does
this mean for care well so we basically
looked at we did an odds ratio to see
you know what was the likelihood of the
physician having a high level of trust
for their patients and if you if you if
you if the patient is using any kind of
non-addictive treatment the level of
trust on the part of the physician Rises
really significantly I mean at most you
know the odds go must go up three times
but you know we see that it is a steep
reduction in trust once we get to
believing you know patients who believe
in opioids works best or patients who
take too much medication
another thing that me and dr. shear and
one of our pre doctoral fellows worked
on was videotaping audio taping
communications between physicians and
chronic pain patients who are asking fir
for for pain medication and we basically
kind of acted did a more broad study
with a focus on not just opioids but any
kind of pain medication and you know
there's one thing is that the one thing
we already know is that the doctor
visits within within the primary care
setting usually take place through a
series of stages there's this opening
stage where people kind of chat and you
know get comfortable and the the the the
physician tries to just kind of do a
little bit of small talk
then the patient presents their
complaint the doctor examines the
patient the doctor you send a diagnosis
the doctor provides the treatment plan
then there's the closing and one thing
we did see was there was quite a lot of
you know going back to the the need to
prove your pain there was a significant
amount of that the visit the patients
were constantly through during these
these these interactions trying to prove
their pain doctors took more time with
opioid patients and there was more
effort put into establishing a
relationship during that during the
opening stage so you know during the
opening stage with a typical opioid
patient they would they would chat and
ask much more questions about their
personal life and how they were doing
and they would try to bring up antidotes
doctors often needed to repeat stages
because patients would communicate new
aspects of chronic pain so they'd be
showing different MRIs and different
other parts of their charts to to to
bring up different types of aspects to
prove that something was going on and
doctors were dealing with significant
ambivalence about opioid use but opioid
users also felt the need to remind
doctors that they are afraid of
addiction
so I think these findings had the
dynamic that plays out when doctors try
to change treatments in any way a
patient isn't comfortable with so
there's been like a recent systematic
review by Frank at all which looked at
when physicians tried to either taper a
patient or provide some sort of
medication to reduce opioid use and they
found that between 21 and a hundred
percent of the patients and
higher-quality students that studies
discontinued to opioid use with their
PCP s however about 21.7%
we're using opioids again during at
follow-up and you know there's a real
mix of quality within these studies but
and there's also you see that there's a
range here to with about zero to forty
five percent using opioids again so why
such a high rate of failure because
intervention efficacy does not just
depend on what is put into them so you
know we see here this flowchart we have
the input we have older females lower
SES higher bercy's pain severity x' low
quality of life high prevalence and
mental health disorders and then there's
the another input is the efficacy of
these interventions with it could be
through lab experiments that can be
pharmaceuticals that we have these these
opioid analgesics or or NSAIDs or other
types of or other types of alternatives
like physical therapy and they're put
into this black box and and after those
inputs are processed through black box
we have the outputs and the outputs are
you know the dependence adequacy of pain
management long-term opioid use the
black box is this mystery and that's
what's that what we need to figure out
in order to make sure that we can reduce
the opiate the long-term opioid use
misuse the dependence and the adequacy
of pain management and we have a problem
translating these interventions through
science into real world settings so this
is a this is a another flowchart by
Powell at all without understanding an
abling factors insurance access to care
organizational factors and institutional
factors we have a very difficult time
understanding why things work and don't
work
so another way of thinking about
physician about physicians and explain
what hat occurs within primary care and
mergency room offices is to think of
physicians as general gatekeepers to the
entire these types of physicians as
general gatekeepers to the entire
healthcare system the system of course
is in is enormous ly complex complex and
they basically have to figure out ways
in which to make their job more
manageable so how do they make their job
more manageable the way that they make
their job more manageable is by their
use of discretion and the word
discretion is used in sociological
literature and a lot of it had been
really heavily used to explain why
people get certain benefits and why some
people get certain benefits and other
people don't get those benefits from
different social programs most notably
from welfare programs but it basically
can be it can be translated over it to
many different fields where somebody
works with the public and they have
power to determine whether somebody gets
something or they don't get something in
this case you know the vision has the
power to determine whether somebody gets
an opioid prescription versus somebody
not getting one so basically the
research on discretion shows that what
what occurs is that people use their
discretion to cope with their working
conditions and by what I mean what what
working conditions is what I mean by
working conditions I mean they're
dealing with a complex system where
there's never enough resources to do to
basically make people healthy there's a
lot of demand I mean you could see this
really clearly within health services
especially when it comes to primary care
there's never enough primary care
doctors people have to wait a long time
to go to see a primary care doctor and
there then there's also the idea problem
of ambiguous goal expectations people
expect these primary care doctors to
make them healthy but what does that
mean and how is that how do how does one
do that sometimes there's very clear
treatments for four health problems but
chronic pain again there's it's it's
very unclear it's very nebulous then
there's the issue of patient leverage I
mean essentially health care patients
are also consumers and and the physician
does have to attract enough of them to
keep a practice going even within large
health systems there's requirements to
have certain numbers of patients and so
so basically you know within the field
of medicine physicians just like any
other kind of field of health services
physicians gain tools to develop
discretionary routines they learn these
routines from other physicians just like
there are you know gatekeeping you know
civil service people learn these
discretionary routines from other people
working in the field and basically it's
these routines that explain what happens
in this black box so essentially about
10% of primary care visits involve
opioid medications so you can see
there's a lot of discretionary opioid
prescribing that goes on primary care
providers provide the majority of care
for chronic pain and that tends to give
more opioids to higher utilizers
patients with increased comorbidity
higher depression nicotine dependence
patients who are older and white have
Medicare insurance and where there is
less state regulation 'el state
regulation constraints
this is a study that I've worked on with
some of the people in my my lab that's
focused on primary cares emergency room
physicians we got a hold of some some
data that basically included some of the
things that went on during the during
the the visits so physicians were able
to record whether or not the patient
requested opioids also they were
recording you know like some of the
patient behaviors like they they they
tended to prefer to have opioids other
other types of medication they didn't
they didn't they used alternative
treatments etc and then we also looked
at pain severity and pain interference
and so patient behaviors seems to to be
an effective deterrent in terms of
whether or not they get opioids so when
a patient seems to be having problems
managing their opioid use the vistas
physician is much more likely to refuse
to give the opioids but the issue but
this seems to wash out once patients
start requesting opioids so it looks
like according to this this bottle two
and three that physicians basically they
are really heavily influenced by patient
requests for opioid so when the patient
gives pressure they are much more likely
to do it and it especially when the
patient has a significant amount of pain
severity so they giving the pressure
there's evidence of pain severity it
really does influence whether or not the
patient gets an opioid
so you know one thing that we have one
thing that we we have is Venice is
becoming more more helpful is the
prescription monitoring programs um this
this is a program that documents opioid
prescribing in a centralized state
database there you know basically almost
every state but my home state of
Missouri has one and they do have
influence on clinician discretion
because they can be theoretically
incorporated easily into the workflow
they're legally mandated but these PDMPs
would sometimes reveal addiction safety
concerns which require physicians to
have to make decisions whether to share
the PDMP
information with clients openly discuss
concerns avoid discussions all togethers
approach discussion confrontationally so
so what would oftentimes happen is
physicians sometimes don't look at these
PDMPs in order to avoid these problems
because they don't want to have to get
into all this difficult all these very
difficult discussions they don't want to
have to switch into this role that they
don't know how to manage of being a
substance abuse treatment counselor and
so a lot of times they avoid it if they
can so primary patients need individual
reasons for tapering so CDC guidelines
Medical Association state federal
regulations also pressure physicians to
her to reduce opioid prescribing however
it again
the long-term opioid users taper
requires negotiation they need
individual Rican reasons they don't need
a physician that just goes there's a CDC
recommendation and this is what you need
to do and the goal is to try to get
patients to taper to do it in a way that
it includes the patient but negotiating
the dosage isn't always possible
these are lengthy difficult discussions
the patients need to be assured that
they will not be abandoned or that they
will they won't necessarily been be
denied opioids in the future so
physicians play a big role in the
provision of opioids but there are also
other important gatekeepers one of those
is pharmacists they they act as a
medication expert on on a health care
team but the opioid crisis makes them
have to try to balance both health and
criminal justice they can refuse to
dispense rather than proactively provide
providing medication so when they see
something that seems that doesn't seem
right with a script that they get they
can they can they can refuse to to scrip
to dispense it they could basically make
phone calls they can call the police if
they see any kind of safety issue but
one problem is is that they are not
trained how to do this in school in in
physician school they usually there's an
assumption that people are coming in
with scripts that are the scripts that
they're supposed to get and that they go
they are supposed to fill them correctly
and to not give the person any serious
problems with it and just give them
specific advice about how to manage that
medication as they take so what happens
is these farm d's oftentimes don't want
to argue with the physicians who
initially you know another issue missus
that they don't want to argue with
physicians who initially provided the
Medicaid
you know another thing that occurred is
that um you know some of these
pharmacists you know they were afraid to
basically call the police or cause
problems with with with patients who
came in with scripts that looked
questionable but if they were in a
dangerous neighborhood or they
oftentimes didn't feel even safe leaving
the facility there the pharmacy so you
know another thing that pharmacists had
been doing was the distribution of
naloxone and you know one of the more
well-known programs for the distribution
of naloxone through pharmacists was the
stop OD New York City program and they
essentially basically included a
specific protocol for pharmacies and a
map to the nearest pharmacy offering
narcan like a nasal spray to prevent
overdose so according to the New York
Times investigation 720 of basically
1,100 pharmacies listed as providing art
NAR cane only a third actually had it in
stock and would dispense it with that
prescription workflow and protocols were
not worked out within pharmacies and
frontline the pharmacists and and the
frontline workers who were there didn't
know the rules it was also very
expensive and so a lot of Mercy student
wanted to you know a lot of a lot of
individuals would come to the pharmacy
to go get the medication and it was too
expensive to pay for it there's similar
issues found with CBS and when it
announced it would provide naloxone
without a prescription
this is a map of of all the different
of all the different programs that that
give kids to lay persons for for
naloxone in the country just actually
kind of interesting
it's from 1996 to 2014 it's about a
hundred and fifty thousand people had
participated in the program and
essentially these kids were a lot of
times given to to lay persons that had
like a family member who had a substance
use disorder or it was given to police
or it was given to to emergency medical
people ambulance drivers um yeah EMS it
was given to EMS and and they were
basically supposed to deliver this
medication to these and these these to
people who are an opioid crisis and you
know studies show that they can they can
and will use these these narcan
medications if they're properly trained
but respondents needed to stay with the
overdosing person so this starts getting
complicated the dose might be
insufficient especially when people are
you know using different kinds of drugs
together poly substance use or they are
using fentanyl and you know most of
these kits went family members and
police officers often feared using these
kits because of liability issues
so you know coming down I you know I
have been aware that a lot of people who
would be watching this this talk might
be basically bench scientists and they
might divide it that might be designing
you know medications or basically doing
laboratory testing or or other types of
things like that that are related to
substance use and so I wanted to
basically just bring home some of these
things I you know to answer some of
those questions before they happen so
you know laboratory testing is
recommended to identify substance use i
mean it's most clear way of determining
whether somebody is using you know
opioids is to basically take a urine
test but it needs to be done along with
safe prescribing so essentially it's
recommended that you know when somebody
gets prescribed opioids they you also
get a urine test laboratory it's
basically more effective than any other
physician tool for detection you're in
testing recommended for pain basically
the urine testing is recommended for
pain management patients so any pain
patient that someone has they should get
a urine test and testing is also
provided provides understanding of all
the drugs taken to ensure no negative
drug interactions and laboratory testing
does not necessarily improve outcomes
and pain management patients so what
does that mean it means that primary
care physicians who see most of the pain
patients have already a difficult time
building trusting positive relationships
with pain patients so if we try to bring
in a urine test which basically says you
can tell us what your you're doing it
what medications you're using but we
don't really trust you we need to have
something to really verify whether
you're lying to us
it brings a lot of a lot more
complexities into the room so for that
reason a lot of physicians are hesitant
to use something like urine test but
this also kind of clarifies how like
some of these simple measures of
screening can cause their own issues
within a primary care environment you
know it you we you also have to consider
when you are creating any kind of new
new types of screening instruments or
treatments how how they fit into a
primary care environment the frontline
professionals specifically physicians
have very little time and don't have
resources there is money within health
systems but there's less money within
primary care and there's there's a
serious problem with time there's a lot
that they need to accomplish within 15
minute time increments leverage needs to
be considered because patients are
voluntary and frontline workers have
specific roles and they feel most
comfortable when they can do those roles
they don't want to take the role of like
I mean a physician doesn't want to take
the role of a policeman you know but a
policeman would be perfect it doesn't
want to take the role of the physician
either so this brings it to a close and
when you bring it to the the last slide
where we say only the one that does not
question is safe from making a mistake
so please feel comfortable asking
questions as you need and I look forward
to hearing from you
the these are the references thank you
dr. van Burt Clark for that informative
presentation I want to remind our
viewers that if they have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now and
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email I'd also like to
thank labrum a kinky days educational
webcast possible before we go in
everyone the today webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2019
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye-bye